[Applause]
so I thought I'd just share with you
briefly some things I'm playing with as
I work on my anti- spin patterns with
stick so of course anything you practice
long enough gets a little
boring and I'm finding ways to entertain
myself and some of them are different
stall
patterns so there's from Diamond anti-
spin I'm playing with stalling up and
down the
stick and of course there's four
varations there's the ones that I find
easier um which I'm going
outwards um let
see outwards up and down the stick with
my right going up the stick for some
reason is easier
than Bo than my left um downwards
o downwards
and also from the right downwards is
awkward so I've got a couple of
favorites and I'm trying to smooth it
all out but the idea is pretty simple um
so I'm just if you're looking for ideas
you can do all this with me that the
stick is already showing me where the
center line is and that also helps me
see what's going right or not going
right if I want my stalls on a clear
Center Line and it really brings me
aware of where my PO fu is going off and
whether I'm really getting to the center
line um both hands at the same
time on the box
antipin playing with these trying to
make nice stalls across and back and to
go right back into a
nice clean box empty
[Music]
Spin and again what I find is that this
one for some reason with the right going
under and back is uh the sloppiest of
the variations so I'm just playing
through it doing the math and finding
different little things I can work on
and my trusty
stick is helping me see whether I'm
making the pract the progress I want to
make it also allows me to do
disappearing AXS
sh
[Music]